Amanda Knox, welcome to the, to the program.
[inaudible], it's been three years now since, since the Supreme court in Italy,
um, acquitted you once and for all, for the last time. Yes. Um,
and, um, you were accused of, of, of being, um,
involved in the murder over your roommate. Yeah.
Uh, have you,
have you spoken to her family after you were, you were
acquitted.
So difficult thing? Um,
I have tried to find ways to reach out. Um,
but I'm aware that there is a very difficult line that I'm walking.
Um,
I know that her family still thinks that I am
involved somehow, at least that's what I've gathered.
And you know, a lot of exonerees deal with this problem where, you know,
a traumatized family is given the impression
that you hurt them and you took something so precious away from them.
And they can't, you know,
separate their emotions from their ability to like
rationally observe objective evidence. And, you know, that's why,
that's why we have a criminal justice system. And, you know, I'm,
I'm not alone amongst exonerees and being, um,
in this difficult place of wanting to reach out, wanting to make a connection,
wanting to grieve together because, you know,
I was never really allowed to grieve. Um, and,
but I also don't want to like, just call them up and be like, hi,
I'm Amanda Knox. You ready to talk to me yet? So I feel like,
I feel like the best thing for me to do is to wait until I get some
kind of sign that it's okay,
because I know that I know what it's like to be triggered and
traumatized by this whole event. And I don't want to put that on them.
And, and of course they, they have their verse and then their,
their idea of what happened, um, on the, um,
what we're going to talk about now is your, your experience. Um,
and the fact that there's, that this there's night of the murder, uh,
you were, you were staying with your boyfriend, um,
and you you've, you've, you've gone to Italy. You were 19 years old,
you'd gone to Italy to just study for a year.
And you met this guy called Raphael and you've been together for a week.
And you, you, you spent the night there, as you say, uh,
and the next morning you came back to the house.
Yeah. You know, um, I came back to the house and I was carrying with me,
you know,
the idea that I going to be going to [inaudible] that weekend with Raphael and
we were going to eat truffles.
And so the last thing on my mind was that I was going to be stumbling into a
tragedy. Um, so, you know,
I carried with me into my house, you know,
this confirmation bias of thinking, Oh, everything's fine.
What did you, what was the first thing you saw? What was.
Yeah,
so I came into my house and the first thing I noticed that the door was open,
the door was right wide open. And I thought that was strange,
but I also didn't jump to the worst conclusion.
I thought maybe the door had just been left, unlocked and blew open.
It was just the two of you living in there, right? No.
Actually we lived with, um, two other Italian roommates.
And so we all live together and, you know, I called out and said,
is anyone home? No one answered. So I just went ahead with my routine.
And over the course of that morning,
I discovered all of these signs that later on the police would say,
you're crazy for not having thought your roommate was dead.
Tell me about those signs. What were the signs?
Yeah, they, you know, there was a few droplets of blood in my bathroom sink.
There was a little blood on a bath mat. Um,
and there was some feces left in a second bathroom. And, you.
Know.
At the time I did not think that I was
coming home to my friend being murdered.
I thought what anyone would think when they came home and saw like a few
speckles of blood here and there, like maybe someone had cut themselves,
maybe someone hadn't been brushing their teeth well enough and their gums were
bleeding. You know,
I did not jump to this incredible conclusion that like,
to me, nothing bad had ever happened to me in my life.
So the idea that like my friend had been murdered was completely
insane to me.
So what, what, what was the turning point here? When did,
when did you realize something was very wrong?
You know, I,
I had the feeling that something was up and I didn't know what it was. Um,
especially when I saw the feces in the toilet. So I went back and asked Rafael,
like, what do you think? And he said, well, call your roommates. Of course,
like, see it. Yeah. I went back to his house and then we went back together.
And when we went back together,
that's when we found that a window had been broken and this room,
this one single room had been rifled through and we thought, Oh my God,
we've been burglarized. Except my room was fined.
Laura's room was fine. And we couldn't open Meredith store.
So we tried to open Meredith store and then eventually Rafael called the police.
I didn't even know how to call the police at that time.
And I called my mom and I called my roommates and we tried to make sense of what
was happening.
And that's when the police arrived and broke down her door and found her body.
And you were there, right? You were outside.
I was there. I did not see her body. Thank goodness. Um,
although, you know, later on in the trial,
I obviously had to see the crime scene footage and it's a horrible,
it's a horrible crime scene. There's blood everywhere. You know, she,
she was,
she apparently fought and struggled for her life and you know,
it, my,
my roommates that did see screamed and cried
for me in that moment,
I was just overwhelmed by trying to keep track of everything that was coming at
me, you know? And, you know, in hindsight, I feel,
I feel silly for not having like put together the pieces,
but really truly
my own confirmation bias coming into that situation was everything's okay,
this is a normal day. And it wasn't,
and that turned into this interesting relationship with the police who like,
they came into the situation with a crime scene and a body and a
terrible bloody mess.
And so they immediately started casting about for worst case scenarios looking
about at us.
Yeah. And you and Rafael came under suspicion quite soon. Yeah. Um,
we have no idea. No, but later on you learn that this, this was also about,
it was about your behavior first your behavior at the crime scene.
What was that behavior?
You know, there's this three second clip that, um,
I'm sure you've seen anyone who's followed the case has seen it this three
second clip where Rafael was outside of the house with
me, it was cold. I was shivering. I was,
I was on the verge of tears. I was trying to figure out what's going on.
So he put his jacket over me and rubbed my shoulders and kissed me three times.
And the kind of incredible thing about this story is the, you know,
the media decided,
especially the tabloid media decided to really strip me of context,
to not show, you know, the hours of time that I was there, helping the police.
They just really honed in on that three second clip of Raphael kissing me and
zoomed in on it and slow mode. And, you know, like, you know,
really just put it on repeat.
So everyone had this impression of me as like this girl who was just kissing all
the time and it wasn't true, you know,
like I was there and I was doing truly what I
thought was going to help. I was doing my best.
And I had no idea that the police had their own confirmation
bias being brought into the equation. They were looking for a murderer.
They were looking for a monster. And so their,
their glasses were tinted that they're silence.
So you have this Italian prosecutor, he,
he had a theory about what had happened.
And he stuck to that theory for a long time. He did. And he told.
Me about that. Yeah. You know,
he stuck to his guns despite overwhelming evidence that pointed to the contrary.
But, you know, we've all heard this story Foxy, Knoxy the femme fatale,
the adulterous Lucifer, Rina.
I was depicted as this who was so jealous of
Meredith's purity that I decided to rape and kill her.
That was the story.
And it what's incredible at this story is it didn't take into consideration that
there was no genetic trace of me at the crime scene.
So.
First they thought it was, but that was contemplated. Yeah.
They, they thought that they had a knife that may have had my DNA on it,
but they knew from the beginning that my DNA was nowhere in
Meredith's room where she had been brutally raped and murdered. So they just,
you know, disregarded that and decided to focus on how can we,
how can we imagine and depict this young woman who is sexually active
as this femme fatale, how can we put her in conflict?
And it's interesting because, you know,
there was this Madonna dichotomy and that false dichotomy was
pushed out into the world. And, and, you know,
people were genuinely intrigued and interested by a story of
two young girls,
maybe some sexual things going on and then ends in murder. And.
And meanwhile, while, while all the world was reading about this, you, you,
you were, uh, uh, held in custody in Italy and,
and you were interrogated quite, quite a lot.
Yes. I,
in the five days from discovering Meredith's death and my
arrest, I was,
I was interrogated for 53 hours and I was interrogated in a
language that I understood about as well as a ten-year-old. Yeah.
And I,
in that interrogation didn't even understand that I was a suspect because the
police told me that I was an important witness and that I was helping them. And,
you know,
over the course of a very brutal interrogation hit me and
threatened me within prison because they said that I was hiding the murderer or
that I had amnesia. And couldn't remember who the murderer was.
And then at one point Raphael changed his story. Didn't they?
Well, what I've understood from what he's,
what he's spoken out about is that they were putting him through the very same,
very dreadful interrogation.
And they pushed him to agree that while he was
asleep, he couldn't say that I was with him.
And so he signed a statement saying that, yes, while he was asleep,
he couldn't say I was there with him.
And then the cops came to my room and said,
your boyfriend has turned against you. We know you're a liar.
You need to tell us what we already know. We know you went out that night,
we know you met with someone.
What w what did you do? Did you stick to your story? Or did you.
I mean, by that point,
I was so scared and confused that I did not know
what was the truth anymore. Like,
I don't know if you've ever had this experience, but, and amazingly,
this happens so often in wrongful convictions,
almost one in four wrongfully convicted people end up giving false admissions.
But what the police tell you is we know what the truth is.
You don't remember the truth. Let us tell you what the truth is.
And if you don't agree to it, you're never getting out of prison again.
And so they made me believe that I had forgotten what happened because I was so
traumatized and I genuine. And they,
what they asked me to do was to not keep telling them the same story,
but to imagine something else, imagine what the truth was.
And the only thing that I could do was react to what they were telling me.
I very genuinely could not believe that the police were lying to me,
that they would manipulate me.
But the fact, the fact that they, they, they,
they leaked your diary to the press.
What do you think was the effect of that? How do you,
how much do you think that had to say?
Yeah. Um, I think that,
I think that it meant that they had decided I was guilty long before any
evidence came into play. I think that they were trying to scare me.
I think they were trying to not only manipulate me and pressure me to say things
and admit to things, but also to like,
give this idea of me and the world that really sustained their theory of
a sex game gone wrong. They had boyfriends, or yes,
I wrote about my boyfriends and I wrote about a lot of things.
I was writing a diary and they decided to
convey to the world that, you know, this,
this list that I had of other men that I'd ever slept with in my whole
entire life actually meant the number of men that I had slept with in a week in
Perugia. And what a look she'll do anything. And what's fascinating is they,
they attacked me through my sexuality.
So because I was a young woman who is sexually active,
that to them meant that I was already guilty and that guilty things
snowballed. If I had sex with people, I could be guilty of anything.
You were, you were convicted to 26 years of prison.
Yeah. Can you describe that moment?
Um, I'm glad you asked about that moment because, um, you know,
I was in prison for two years leading up to that verdict.
And throughout those two years,
I was so sure that everything was going to turn out all.
I was so sure that it didn't matter that like I was being portrayed in this
crazy way, because it wasn't true and what was true mattered.
And my innocence would save me.
And so when the verdict was handed down,
I, um, I was,
I was crushed and not just crushed, like, you know,
that physical weight that hits you, which it did,
but like I was crushed in an existential way. This,
the whole world had decided that I was guilty.
And so they had effectively rewritten reality.
They had rewrote my past and my present and my future.
And suddenly I was faced with the prospect of, Oh,
I'm not just an innocent person. Who's just waiting to go home.
I'm a prisoner and prison is my home.
And the truth doesn't matter. And.
So it was like this Dawn on you that very moment.
Yeah. I, until that moment,
I was so sure that the courtroom was kind of like a scientific laboratory where
a bunch of information gets boiled down to truth beyond a reasonable doubt.
And in fact,
what I discovered is the courtroom was a battleground of storytelling where like
the most emotionally compelling story and not necessarily the most truthful
wins. And so, you know,
the prosecution and the tabloid media came up with a story that people loved.
People loved Foxy Knoxy they loved to hate her and they
sentenced her, but that they couldn't, you know,
take this invented person and put her in prison. That was me.
I was the one who had to go back to the prison van.
I was the one who had to go back to the bars and the barbed
wire and the loneliness.
It's, um, it's in a way, it's a story about,
about much more than, than a new,
it's a story about conception and how,
how tragedy can be turned into some kind of big entertainment,
because I look back on a lot of the coverage and the
tragedy in a way it's all gone. It's,
it's really like, I don't know if do you ever,
did you ever read about it later? Did you see some of the coverage later?
I mean, I was aware that there was a lot of coverage,
but not to the extent that I saw when I got out.
Um, you know,
that became very apparent to me when I was being chased by paparazzi for
months, or I couldn't, you know,
go outside my mom's house without them waiting for me.
They're waiting to like yell things at me. Like,
do you think Meredith has been forgotten?
And the idea that I had to answer for their coverage of
the case seemed to fly completely over their heads. You know, um,
I think that something that happens when someone is accused of a terrible crime
and a terrible crime happens,
we tend to stop treating those people.
Like we would someone else we've decided that they're an other.
And as soon as they're in other, all those like negative emotions that,
and fears and fantasies that we have,
we feel entitled to project them onto that person.
And we don't give them the benefit of the doubt because emotionally we're just
triggered that way. And I don't think that that means that we're bad.
I just think that that means we're human and we make this mistake over and over
and over again. And, you know,
I never thought this kind of thing happened until it happened to me.
And then I came home and I was introduced to hundreds of
other men and women,
but mostly black men in my country who had been depicted
as monsters when they were really just people.
And another thing I learned was like,
I lived alongside actual killers and actual thieves.
In the brilliant prison. You spent a total of how long in prison?
Four years. Yeah. And, you know,
I was living alongside people who had done terrible things,
but they were people too.
And that's something that I don't think people really think about.
Do you think those four years
and the eight years that this,
this case took over your life in a way before you were acquitted finally. Yeah.
Do you, uh, how has it shaped you? How has it changed you?
Gosh. Um, well,
I can tell you that I did not want to be the girl who was wrongly accused of
murder. That was not something that I ever aspired to. Um,
and very honestly,
when I was released from prison and I was allowed to come home,
even though I was still on trial and I was facing another four years of
trial, um, I wanted the life that I had before,
because I didn't like the idea that who I was was,
was defined by something that just happened to me,
not by something I did or something that I deserved, but like,
you know,
I went back to school and no matter how many poetry classes I took there,
it was staring me in the face.
The fact that I had pain and fury,
the fact that I would forever be associated with Meredith's
death, whether it was true or not.
There, there is a man in jail for this murder today. Uh,
and you are acquitted,
but do you feel that you are totally acquitted in the public eye?
It depends on who you ask. Right? Um,
when I'm living my day to day life,
I feel very seen by the people who are close to me.
That doesn't mean that the world knows the
truth about what happened to Meredith, you know, for
the man who committed this murder,
he left DNA all over Meredith spotty.
He left his footprints and fingerprints in her blood, in the crime scene.
He was a burglar who was known to commit crimes like these.
And yet for all the international attention,
this case received very few people know his name.
His name is Rudy, good day. He murdered Meredith,
but the public and the prosecution and the tabloid media all decided to focus
on me instead as if,
as if my demeanor or what clothes I was wearing that day, or what might,
you know, what it looked like if I was looking this way or that way,
somehow held some deep truth about what happened. And that's not true.
There was evidence there to look at.
And, um, this is part of your, your life today, is that under the,
um, part of the reason you sit here is that you work with other women
that has been, you talk a lot with other women that has been shamed in,
uh, in, in, in the public eye.
I've become very sensitive to how women's narratives are stolen from them.
Can you, what can you say to them? What do.
Well, one thing I can say is,
I know another thing that I can say is, look,
I understand better than anyone that if you are stripped of context
and no one treats you with compassion, like another human being,
you're no one's ever going to really see you.
And the truth is never going to be really known because the two dimensional,
tabloid versions of ourselves that are out there in the world, they don't,
they don't represent us. So, you know,
when I set out to tell the stories of other women who had been treated
similarly to me,
I've thought I was facing this terrible uphill battle who would ever care what
Foxy Knoxy had to say about some other train wreck woman.
Surprisingly people responded very well.
I think a lot of women have been waiting to confront something that's
felt wrong all along this exploitation of women's bodies and stories.
And when they finally saw someone who had felt it on their own skin in a
really bad way, just say, um, no, I'm a person here.
She is too. Like, it's very easy to humanize someone.
You just have to sit in a room with them. It's it's my job is not that hard.
I just have to be there and be a human with them and care. You.
Have to describe your story as a modern day witch hunt.
Yeah. Um, well I think that,
I think that I was treated like a monster and that people
felt entitled to hunt me down.
I felt hunted down for my entire adult life.
And the moment that the Italian Supreme court fully acquitted me
for having nothing to do with this crime,
I cannot tell you the relief. And you know,
that didn't mean that I suddenly, you know,
everything was gone and everything was okay because I was still entering into a
world who had S had seen Foxy Knoxy and was ready to judge
her.
And so I knew that like every person I would meet from now on would have already
judged me before ever meeting me.
Do do, do you still, do you still struggle with, with this?
Um, I do. Um,
it's interesting because I think the story has become more complex.
People have been given access to, uh,
to not just the prosecution story, but to the bigger story.
And what I'm trying to do is show how this isn't just an isolated incident,
but like part of like this bigger issue that we have of who do we
treat as someone like ourselves and who would we treat as other and why do we do
it? And is this a mistake?
I think it is a big mistake and there are incredibly terrible consequences.
And th this is why you want to talk to all the people,
all the people that has been shamed,
other people that have been victims of similar, similar things. Yeah.
Um, has it been difficult and I'm asking you,
because I met your boyfriend like backstage here, has it been difficult to,
to start again, to trust people again, to, to just start a new,
new life in a way after this?
Yeah. Um, funnily enough,
I'm I have a really nice origin story with my boyfriend.
Can I share it with you? Yeah. Um,
so for a while I was writing, um,
arts correspondence for a local newspaper. And when I first started there,
I was writing anonymously because I did not want anyone to like, be mean to me.
But after a while, I started writing under my own name.
And I was given this book, this advanced copy of a debut novel,
and I read it and I reviewed it,
and it was hilarious and heartbreaking and funny and smart.
And I wrote this great review and that was going to be the end of it.
Except the very next day I walked out of my apartment and across the street,
I saw this poster for this book reading for this exact book that I had just
read. And so I said, Hey, I'm not doing anything tonight.
I'm going to go to this book reading. So I did,
and I witnessed like this beautiful bromance between these two best friends who
had written a novel together, Chris and Gavin,
and I immediately them for an interview. So they said, sure, that's great.
So I went to their house. I was sitting across from them just like you,
and did the interview, had the questions ready,
but then that kind of devolved into drinking scotch and watching star Trek,
and then wandering out into the neighborhood into the night. And it,
it was the most fun. And at the end of the night,
Gavin gave me this big bear hug and Chris shook my hand and said,
we should be friends.
And that was maybe a month or two after I had been fully acquitted.
And the idea that I could have friends that I could just meet people out in the
world and they could be my peers and we could have a connection, um,
was so new to me that was not something that I could do when I was
on trial. And then, you know,
we became friends and then nine months later we started dating and we've been
together ever since. So yeah.
[Inaudible] so much, I
hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.